tyrod taylor currently right now is the
quarterback for the houston texans
along with deshawn watson amazing so you
think about
what possibly could happen we don't know
but
a guy who i can ask and get some of the
questions that i think a lot of people
want answered
as aaron wilson at aaron wilson nfl on
twitter covers the houston texans
for the houston chronicle and i guess
aaron
it's thursday what's the temperature
today
on everything surrounding deshawn watson
just for today i guess
well you know obviously it's a very
upsetting time
for you know for fans of deshawn and you
know for
those closest to him and i've been in
touch with i was actually just on the
phone with
um someone that he's in a business deal
with he's also one of his close friends
lefty's cheesesteak sam berry who's the
owner and founder of that restaurant
chain and deshawn is an equity partner
and
yeah he's been trying to you know keep
desean encouraged with the spirits it's
uh
very upsetting obviously you can imagine
what's like to be accused of what he's
being accused of so yeah
they're you know they're calling him one
of the filings you know called the woman
called him a quote serial predator uh
the 14th lawsuit of the 16th they were
filed all civil litigation
all innocent to proven guilty no
criminal proceedings and
yeah this is a man who's uh you know and
for the fight of his life his reputation
his good name is
is on the line and uh because as
everyone's told me
yeah he's embarrassed he's upset he's
angry you know it's frustrating uh
talking to his high school football
coach he's not very upset
he said he can't even get on social
media because of what people are saying
and he's you know what i'm getting from
his inner circle is this is just
incongruous with his character and what
they know of him and
they are in disbelief they don't believe
the allegations
and they are asking everyone to
give it time and you know let it play
out
you know aaron when you first caught
wind of this right when these
allegations
these lawsuits when all this you know
started to get stirred up a little bit
did you expect to get to where it's at
right now currently
word scenes as you mentioned the
lawsuits are piling up the litigation is
now
starting to pile up did you expect
expect it to get this big
no no i don't think anyone thought that
he would sign up this many
plaintiffs the attorney i'm referring to
tony busby former mayoral candidate
high profile lawyer here who's in a
legal battle with deshaun watson who's
represented by rusty hardin
roger clemens and adrian peterson's
former attorney and
high profile guy himself uh really
actually bigger
than tony but they're both you know big
time lawyers
i thought that what he would face would
be you know one case or
a few cases and when i saw deshawn
that evening respond on social media
and how he characterized it i thought
well maybe
you know he's going to have some
problems
correct we didn't think it would get to
this depth and that there would be this
many
litigants we're only at 16 cases uh tony
busby in a press conference that he has
spoken to
22 women so he may sign up additional
plaintiffs and they're all jane doe's
because
you know they're they're anonymous they
have also uh you know his camp brian
bernie is this should have sworn
affidavit uh that they released saying
that one of the women
uh was trying to blackmail deshaun and
acknowledge that they had a consensual
uh exchange and then you know that the
woman asked for 30 000
they denied it they didn't meet that
uh and now they're in a legal fight
so yeah no i didn't think that it would
get to be this many i don't think anyone
could predict that the only one that
would have really known that would have
been the plaintiffs
and tony busby and i don't think rusty
harden
who was you know hired after this
situation started to
spiral you know he's getting his no
hands around it he's trying to uh you
know battle back and
knowing talking to you know rusty
talking to
you know deshaun's camp yeah they're
taking it very seriously and they're
uh you know it's it's a tough situation
obviously it's emotional
and one thing um you know that everyone
has to
respect is the legal process and no one
should
you know shame victims or you know
things like that and they're not doing
that they're just
you know trying to stick with facts and
i think everybody needs to respect the
legal process
and there's a court of public opinion
there's the
actual courts and you know then there's
the nfl investigation which is parallel
we're speaking with aaron wilson it
covers the houston texans for the
houston chronicle and you mentioned his
name a couple times the lawyer tony
busby
and he's kind of i'm looking at his
tactics
so far and how he has went about this
situation and he's going to instagram
he's going to
social media and yet you don't actually
have any kind of
criminal lawsuits just yet this has all
been sort of civil
but just the tactics of tony busby has
that really caught people off guard as
he made this thing really such
a public situation that is really
smearing regardless of the outcome
desean watson to where no matter what
he's almost guilty
well i'm sorry if he asked that
questions quickly again
i was just returning facts i apologize
yeah just his
the social media aspect of it the way
that tony busby
has went about 20 bucks doing that yes
well it's it's the equivalent
the modern way of putting the ad on tv
have you ever seen like
have you uh you know been injured on the
job have you had uh have you ever been
exposed to asbestos if so call the
this law firm right it's the same thing
yeah and i know that people are saying
well that's we're looking looking down
on it but
and you know yeah as rusty harden caught
a circus like atmosphere created by tony
buzzy that was his characterization not
mine
it is the modern day equivalent of
saying
if you got a case hit me up
and we'll talk about it and then maybe
he'll sign them up maybe he won't
but my point is it doesn't necessarily
if you think about it
it's there's nothing illegal or
necessarily even unethical
it'd be the same thing if you know
whether it's a television
realm or social media it's like a free
advertisement
and that's his social channel just like
he can use his facebook and he does use
his facebook account
people might not like it but that
doesn't mean there's anything wrong with
that
and you know i think
that's kind of i know that it seems like
that's crazy you know and he does say
some things on instagram that
you could say wow you know that's that's
a lot um you know and he
yeah he offers his opinion most lawyers
don't do that but he's a different style
lawyer
he's a guy that had a sherman tank
parked in front of his
actually i lived pretty close to him
except i live in the high rise and he's
got some mansion uh like kyle mcnair the
texans owner but yeah he had a tank
parked out front
you know he's had a dui before that he
beat he's also really powerful he's on
the board of regents for texas a
m and it's a big time booster for the
aggies sports program
so he wanted them to draft johnny
manziel this guy is someone that
really pushes the envelope and
he's incredibly wealthy and he's you
know he's going to do what he wants
they're different rusty and him have a
much different style
rusty is a lot quieter and more like
low-key
uh just sort of a old-school
southern gentleman-style lawyer
and i've dealt with rusty on other
things and
yeah i think he's someone that you know
they just have a different style and
there's actually uh in our newspaper has
been writing a lot about this as of uh
not as much as our court reporter
they're
different styles and the way they
approach this case you know you really
have kind of a legal heavyweight
battle here for two of the bigger
lawyers in town and
it's a pretty big city uh but those guys
are two of the biggest guns
you know aaron i know the houston texans
cannot comment any more than they
already have
about what's going on with their
quarterback and deshaun watson
but from the sense that you get what
what is the feeling
that the houston texans the organization
is having but also
the fan base with what's been taking
place
um you know with him asking to be traded
there are some fans that
you know they're they're going in on him
they're uh you know like
their attitudes like well you don't want
to play here anymore so
you know i think that's feeding some of
the you know social media
reaction um because
some people are immature or maybe enjoy
other people's troubles
uh as you can imagine with some of the
more salacious details are being made
fun of
and you know i've had even you know
people in the sports industry you know
they're
have a laugh about it and but you know
i would say you know and i actually
approached this as a
i've covered ray rice i've covered ray
lewis these things eventually do
move on and i'll ask you a question
is ben roethlisberger in just your first
opinion accused rapist sexual assaulter
or just veteran super bowl winner what
do you think of first
i think we uh think of the veteran super
bowl winner first right because
yeah is he a hall of fame quarterback or
is he a guy that allegedly sent
pictures of his penis to a woman yeah we
think about faith
ray lewis maybe a little bit more of a
greyer ray lewis accused murderer just
hall of fame
linebacker great linebacker one of the
best ever
my point is eventually the story changes
but you have to get through all that i
covered ray rice
ray rice will always be known for the
punch because there's a video
and he never played again that's
different
that's why i would say where it differs
but does sean watson's gonna play
football again and he's not going to
jail this is a civil matter
this can be fixed with money you might
face a suspension your trade might be
delayed
you might not play football this year
all those are legitimate scenarios
all that said there'll be a second act
for him
and i think by the time he celebrates
his 26th birthday he's playing in a
different city
in all likelihood and he's
you know probably has some sort of you
know image repair
enough for in front of him and an
apology tour but the fact is this is the
passing yardage champion from last year
and a three-time promo passer
of course he's gonna play football again
and he'll make it back
but it just started this is a week old
so everybody's like well what's gonna
happen how will this happen i don't know
but i have a good feel for it that
eventually the cases get worked out one
way or another they get thrown out or
settled or however
or you know it gets disposed of
the nfl probably will punish them
they're already investigating
they don't let things go despite lack of
criminal charges
and then but i think everybody's gonna
let it play all
let it play out because it's gonna take
a lot of time these things
don't just get cleaned up in a new york
minute
we're talking months and months and it
could even be a year
as i would just say as david cornwell
who represented ben roethlisberger told
me this week
deschamps have to realize you cannot
make this thing go any faster
than it's going to when you accept that
you can't accept it you know you're
going to be in the thick of this for a
while
and that i think it's the reality that
really does ring true that
it's going to be a long process he
covers the houston texans for the
houston chronicle he's aaron wilson
a couple more minutes with you before we
let you go here erin but
obviously you say this is going to take
time and the nfl
is still going to keep operating they
still do have a draft coming up there
are still
transactions and things being handled
being made
and the houston texans how do they
operate
with so much right now going on with
just the
the chaos of what's going on with
deshawn watson
how do they move forward maybe not
knowing if they'll have their
quarterback available or not
to answer your question nick casario
he's already signed
cut tyrod traded over 40 players and
signed to rod taylor
right so he's already done all that and
so they have
their you know stand in for deshaun
watson
if deshawn watson doesn't play for them
he doesn't desean obviously you guys you
know
he doesn't want to play for them and he
said he'll never play another down for
these guys
so you know where does that leave them
i think you know with toronto taylor you
know if they can't work a trade
and i don't think that they can now
because of this situation
and the team's being really having pause
because of
you know the allegations yeah i think
they've already moved on
they've already done stuff they traded
for ryan finley they have a backup
they can draft a quarterback when they
sign another quarterback
they'll have three quarterbacks at camp
i'm sure and
the moves most of them are obviously
they didn't have a lot of cap space
a lot of one-year deals but you know if
you guys like lindsay and mark ingram
and trading for shaq
loss and then marcus cannon and um
adding kevin pierre lewis and desmond
king
yeah they've been doing roster moves
it's a bunch of you know one year and
two year deals the only three-year
contract was for their new punter
cameron johnson former eagles punter
so primarily it's a lot of short-term
stuff and
they're just trying to you know change
the culture make the team more
competitive
and they turned over the majority of the
roster already so yeah nick casaro has
been busy
uh they they're not distracted by
deshaun at all
i would say if anything he's laser
focused and he's
getting his you know work in and the
whole personnel department
they're busy yeah they're not letting
anything with deshawn
his situation his trade demands all of
those things
no i don't think it's just hurt them at
all they're doing their job
well aaron i appreciate all the info and
i appreciate the time and definitely uh
getting caught up on what's the latest
on this desean watson news man
appreciate the time
all right thanks bye that's uh aaron
wilson covers the texans for the houston
chronicle hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here